yeah I wish to keep my family happy to
be a lot of time with them and not too
much at work
so to continue investing time in uh in
my personal life as well it's very easy
to be fully delegated to work and never
touch your guitar again and then that's
what I wish for myself
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside fam Fusion VC Birthright Excel
J impact leap Google for startups and
hippo and in media partnership with
C-Tech
foreign
we're going to talk about productivity
workplace productivity generative Ai and
obviously the most the you know the
biggest emerging technology I think that
we've been hearing about and speaking
about over the last eight months or so
and so we're gonna dive into how your
new company as co-founder and CTO what
you're doing there but but you also have
a remarkable experience all over the
place from from open web uh to to gone
to Mobile so you know really really cool
background working with some some of the
most amazing companies here and and so
I'm excited to dive into what you're
doing today again thank you for being
here
uh thanks for the intro great well and
tell me a little bit about your you know
your relationship with technology as an
as sort of as an engineer and product so
that we can you know understand a little
bit your mindset better uh so my journey
with technology honestly started at the
young age my father was like a big IBM
kind of guy led the it at IBM Israel so
I test computer from a very early stage
uh hacked it developed game developed a
lot of fakes and my deeper passion for
it honestly started with the iPhone when
the iPhone was released I was mind blown
started immediately coding for it I
honestly barely had enough money to get
a Mac so I did the Hackintosh trick back
in the days so it was fun days and I
started developing apps getting into it
developing camera apps many things
uh during the years I've been developing
a lot of products my passion is honestly
more so for product than for for
technology I use technology to to solve
the pains and the problems that I really
want to solve and since the iPhone I
believe generative AI is the only other
time that my mind was blown with what
you can do like I was amazed by the
multi-touch and how advancement the
iPhone brought in and I have to say this
is the only time nothing happened to me
again was a few years back when I
started seeing Gans and what uh deep
learning can do actually
so you're seeing games you're seeing
what deep learning can do what's going
through your mind what what is sort of
you know your your executive yet
entrepreneurial mindset taking you well
what's the process
um so like I mentioned before it always
starts with problems that I'm facing and
how can it be solved so when I see the
generative models and gains a lot of the
problems that are already in my mind I'm
starting to think about how can we solve
them how can this be productive now as a
amateur musician a lot of it went to how
can I create music with it but there's a
VPR in the open web and the more
concrete problems I saw how can I solve
is how can we help people do more with
their time using generative Ai and
that's it let me after a lot of Trials
to to summarization which isn't the most
trivial thing about generative AI most
people look at it as how can I generate
videos the fake videos maybe or how
could I generate images and even create
a new email but honestly I was looking
at it from how can I create less content
there's too much going on work why can
someone process it for me and help me
just figure out what's going on
yeah I love it okay so
um I love the mindset love the
transition and we're talking about
um you know summarization uh gist
obviously you know great great name for
a company and um you know paint me the
picture of the of you know the potential
here the uh the opportunity that's
presented once you sort of re-examine or
rethink the way that we're CR you know
we're we're digesting information and
how generative Ai and summarization can
be you know really fundamentally helpful
here
so the opportunity is huge I believe
it's pretty obvious to most people that
you talk with that there's just too much
going on whether it's your mom with your
WhatsApp groups or iMessage with the
gigantic amount of messages flying in
there or at work we're in slack for
example where again people are
blabbering and talking a lot some of it
is important that a lot of it is about
what we're having for lunch and it means
that you just reach through to
understand if it's interesting and not
even talking about Twitter and emails
and all the Articles going on in the
world so the opportunities honestly to
help every human being which is
interfacing with the digital device and
going on the internet want to help them
gist it having said that of course our
Market is the workspace and helping
people do their job first and not
solving this problem for the entire
world
yeah for sure and so
um common use cases for when people need
to to have a service like this for their
work for their daily work well how do
you perceive it
sure so the first product we released
was the gist for slack and the use case
is basically having too much
conversations going on in too many
channels in slack and just getting a
digest of it so you can get your digest
on demand when you slash gist in slack
or as a daily schedule where you can
follow topics or specific channels now
we're going to take
a thousand words and turn them into two
sentences of what happened there we're
going to understand if it's of interest
to you even though you're in the channel
doesn't mean you're interested in it and
we're gonna digest it to just what
matters so we do this in slack and our
goal is to do this across all the tools
you use
interesting and so you're so effectively
it's the it's the ability to
to really you know distill the the most
critical pieces that that would allow
for you to take actionable measures you
know based on based on whatever you know
conclusion you came up with I guess part
of the problem is that you create we're
creating you know in these long
summaries or these or these a lot of
content then you miss out on the on the
really the gist of it which is the
action that needs to be taken or the
lesson to be learned from from this
content and it gets pushed into some
envelope hidden in some drawer somewhere
exactly
cool and so let's talk a little bit
about the technology and uh and and you
know generative AI in general how what
what that supplies for a company like
just in in 2023 what does it look like
to build a company a generative AI
company in early 2023.
first of all it's very exciting I have
to say like everybody is hearing this
podcast I'm sure I've been looking at
the advancement at this stage so I
wouldn't call us per se a generative AI
focused company because a lot of our
technology is actually about creating a
graph of your work data understanding
what interesting connecting the dots
between tools that are related and our
last mile is using generative AI in
order to digest that for you
so we are using all the advancements the
open source and a lot of the advancement
in the generator I feel in order to
create these really awesome stories
enables you to ask questions about the
data that we detected
um so on the one hand it's exciting and
we're getting a lot of benefit without
investing all of our efforts everything
generative AI but but it almost feels
like this is a part of the you know the
Natural Evolution of the of this sort of
this deep learning infrastructure that
started you know in sort of 2015 and
attention is all you need Etc and so it
almost feels like the technology is
progressing so quickly and at the same
time these infrastructure layers are
getting built for these applicative
application based companies how do you
how do you keep up with
you know latest advancements because you
want to make sure that your
you know at The Cutting Edge and ahead
of the game at the same time you want to
be lean and and to focus on product so
how do you
how do you balance these two
so to be very clear we do not focus
about advancing generous DVI models we
are focusing on utilizing what everybody
else is progressing and many thanks to
the companies like Google Facebook and
Microsoft but we're focusing our time on
Gathering the data and on the product
itself on creating a graph understanding
what's connected to what and leaving the
Our Last Mile which is a big part of our
product to what we utilize from open
source Solutions yeah that makes sense
and
one of the things that I became very
curious about in generative AI is the
user experience portion and that's so
and you know you'll see you've also held
a significant product positions and so
you you appreciate the in both sides and
and so what is a you know what are the
the things to consider when it comes to
user experience
interacting with a product like that of
just sure
um so there are a few interesting
aspects of it the the first obvious one
is is speed like when you want to
process and create Advanced usages of
generative AI it doesn't necessarily
come in very quickly as for example
we're trying to process a huge amount of
data and speed is a is a very important
matter and
another aspect is how you actually
validate that's what you generate from
this generative models is actually
correct
I'm sure many of the people here use
generative models such as chat GPD ask
it the questions and it's just mumbles
something that looks correct but it's
not correct sure again a lot of the
product and technological effort we are
focusing in is to make sure that how we
summarize is always correct is based on
the data that we collected and not
something that the model can just
automatically create it can elaborate a
bit more about it but I'm not sure we
have enough time for that no no I would
love that I think that this would be
very interesting okay sure so generally
speaking one of the issues everyone is
familiar with is that these models can
generate anything they were trained in
order to complete based on text from the
open web uh very soon being would
probably release some kind of Google
Searchlight feature that tries to tell
you about everything that you search for
and that's the main issue in the
generative engineering uh
models it's very hard to measure it when
it's based on plane model so what are we
we're focusing on is actually detecting
the results beforehand and making sure
the generative model only generates
something that is highly related and
relies on the data that we've collected
not something that would just
be popped up from the model so for
example even if we train a generative
model on the company's data and enable
free prompts to generate any questions
of it that might cause a lot of the the
results or the answers to be incorrect
so we have developed a few technical
ways to make sure that the data is
always correct and how important is the
human in the loop for for this process
so you have the technical aspects of how
you are able to I guess evaluate or
assess your own performance but what
about that of the human interaction
so specifically in the way that we do it
yeah it's not critical for the success
of the summaries because of how we
collect the data in and serve it but we
do collect always as much human feedback
as possible that when people share these
summaries or give us feedback about them
we learn a lot implicitly and explicitly
in there very cool so tell me a little
bit about yourself you know you're done
a lot you've been a part of some amazing
companies
so you're you know on one hand You're
Building you know a generative AI
startup and you know the hottest time
for AI ever and it sounds like with with
a product that that you know this the
shift will be you know there will be a
shift where people use Ai and generative
AI to transform you know whatever
knowledge we have or create to that to
to these coherent pieces and you're
talking about a specific use case of
that
um but on the other end you're still
building a startup and you're you're
leading you know the you're leading the
technology vision for the startup and as
a co-founder what do you what are you
bringing with you to this journey that
you're taking away from you know your
background your history and it's a it's
always a question I like to ask them
people that have a lot of experience go
on go on these new Journeys
so
one of the main things in bringing with
me from past experiences is my
co-founder it'sic which I've been
working with for the past 10 years
and so that's the main thing we've both
tackled a lot of problems mostly related
to data and consumer products so
we have a lot of experience in how to
create growth for example even if we
create a very cool product growth is
still a core thing we need to tackle as
a startup or how we hack this growth
and I have to say we've implemented a
lot of it and how to build our current
product and how to have been scaled
which is a YouTube challenge
other than that resiliency I have to say
I've built growth startup early stain
startup it's always hard you always need
to continue doing what you do and be
resilient and
just never give up I believe that's one
of the best advices that I believe in
for startup is don't give up too quickly
those who continue with that line tackle
it again and again and again are the
ones that essential is going to to win
it at the end
in which part do you enjoy most in the
process
the speed Spades and touching the market
when you work at growth stage or larger
companies we all know how it feels
everything is slow
so speed I believe it's the thing that's
most the most fun to me releasing things
every day every two days seeing how to
interact with I mean we've just released
the gist for slack like two months ago
we already have
yeah I don't want to say the number but
a lot of companies both big and small
fortune 500 a lot of people so it's it's
moving really fast so it's very exciting
so you're you're
so you enjoy working on things that are
very high touch very you know that are
very you know product-led growth
oriented see how people respond to them
you see how people interact with your
product and you can just nail it right
yeah
exactly and I have to say we've actually
considered when we started to start off
like how do we grow it do we go with B2B
sales do we go to the CEO and tell him
hey everybody in your company needs it
or we go to the person at the end to the
engineer the product manager and give
them just start using it so
after I'm giving a lot of thought we are
a lot more of plg people we know how to
build consumer products it's a lot more
fun so honestly
was there a reason not to do that for
you not to go on the plg route
damn a lot of B2B startups they try to
do the B2B sales from the top required
to close the company try to use the
relations here to Israel like we know a
lot of companies 30 as well my partner
it's a really has been in the industry
for 25 years he was letting companies
like blizzard and Wix so it we had a lot
of connection here at Israel the movie
field she is kind of not using a lot of
it in order to use your real passion and
skill which is just to release a product
that product content have it
interestingly enough
yeah no completely if you look if you're
looking ahead
um you know two three years four years
down the line what do you think will be
the differentiators that will make
just you know successful or not you know
what really are the core elements that
that would make the difference here
then I believe it's Simplicity we're
working on a complex product we have to
keep it on the one hand simple so that
everyone in the organization can use it
and not just the most advanced people
who want to get the very Advanced job
done like from the get-go we're trying
to keep the product super simple you
just let's just in slack you get a
summary we will have to continue having
it simple while we integrate more and
more tools into a place where you can
actually adjust everything that's going
on at work
so that's going to be a key factor for a
growth you should believe the second one
is to utilize your learnings from one
company to another say our goal is to
create a system that can integrate to
the organization data and organizations
have a lot of data to learn from each
other we believe then in five years from
now organization which would not utilize
Machinery models or AI for internal use
cases or how to help their employees be
better they would just not uh would not
be able to compete with the rest of the
companies so we would need to utilize
what how the global company data can
utilize a specific company to be better
because it's definitely possible I think
we don't know
last question but uh maybe the most
important one here what do you wish for
yourself on this journey
what I wish good question
I wish to keep my family happy to be a
lot of time with them and not too much
at work
so to continue investing time in uh in
my personal life as well it's very easy
to be fully delegated to work and never
touch your guitar again and then that's
what I wish for myself I I'm gonna need
a I'm gonna need your help with that
ever since I created my own thing I have
I don't I haven't seen the light outside
of the office and so I I can resonate
with that well it I thank you so much
for this time and for the energy and the
insights it's a pleasure talking to you
and meeting you and getting to hear your
story so thank you very very much thanks
for having me
[Music]